[Música]
Estas son las noticias de France 24
Pedro Castillo fue destituido del cargo
de presidente de Perú y está bajo
custodia policial por ciento un votos el
congreso aprobó la moción de censura que
puso fin a su mandato un hecho que tuvo
lugar solo horas después de que el mismo
Castillo anunciara la disolución del
legislativo
la policía de Alemania frustró un
atentado contra el parlamento del país
25 integrantes de un grupo de
ultraderecha fueron arrestados en un
operativo a Escala Nacional según la
fiscalía alemana tenían el objetivo de
acabar con el orden Estatal e instalar
un nuevo liderazgo en ese país europeo
y comenzó oficialmente en la ciudad de
Montreal en Canadá la conferencia de
Naciones Unidas sobre biodiversidad Cup
15 el encuentro tiene como meta
concretar un acuerdo histórico entre los
190 países asistentes para salvar
especies y ecosistemas de un daño
Irreversible Tenemos reporte desde
Canadá en unos minutos
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 soy Santiago López
González Gracias por estar con nosotros
hasta ahora vamos a comenzar en Perú el
intento de disolución del Congreso por
parte del presidente Pedro Castillo
finalizó con la destitución y con la
detención del mandatario Castillo
buscaba gobernar por decreto también
convocar a unas nuevas elecciones
parlamentarias y también redactar una
nueva constitución para ese país horas
después en una sesión extraordinaria del
Congreso los parlamentarios aprobaron su
destitución ahora una mujer por primera
vez en la historia del país asumió el
cargo de presidenta
fue una decisión que le costó el cargo a
tan solo horas de que fuera votada una
moción de censura en su contra en el
legislativo Pedro Castillo decretó el
cierre del Congreso e instauró Un
gobierno de excepción que le permitía
gobernar por decreto
convocar en el más breve plazo a
elecciones para un nuevo congreso con
facultades constituyentes para elaborar
una nueva constitución en un plazo no
mayor de nueve meses a partir de la
fecha y hasta que se instaure el nuevo
el nuevo congreso de la república se
gobernará mediante decretos ley la
decisión Fue catalogada mayoritariamente
como un golpe de estado por múltiples
sectores Y en cuestión de horas el
presidente se quedó solo la avalancha de
renuncias comenzó la primera fue la de
su canciller César Landa otros ministros
y Embajadores siguieron El ejemplo
mientras que la policía y las fuerzas
armadas se metieron un comunicado
confirmando que no acataban la orden del
presidente el congreso en vez de
atemorizarse por las palabras Castillo
inició el voto de la moción de vacancia
ha sido dos del artículo 113 de la
constitución política del Perú
concordante con el artículo 117 de la
carta política En consecuencia se
procederá al régimen de sucesión
presidencial establecido en el artículo
115 de la constitución política del
Estado ciento uno de los 130
congresistas votaron por destituirlo por
permanente incapacidad moral sólo seis
optaron por el no al conocerse la
noticia de su destitución fue detenido y
posteriormente llevado ante la fiscalía
en donde se le vio junto a su ministro
del interior mientras firmaban
documentos su vicepresidenta Dina
boluarte acudió al congreso y asumió
como nueva presidenta del país cargo que
primera vez es ostentado por una mujer
asumo el cargo de presidenta
constitucional de la República siendo
consciente de la enorme responsabilidad
que me toca y mi primera invocación como
no podía ser de otra manera es convocar
a la más amplia unidad de todas y todos
los peruanos la nueva presidenta estará
inicialmente en funciones hasta 2026
cuando abría elecciones aunque con la
incertidumbre política que atraviesa el
país desde hace años no es posible
vislumbrar si llegara al final de su
periodo
a 16 años de prisión fue condenado el
expresidente de Guatemala Otto Pérez
Molina así lo dio a conocer la justicia
de su país el exmandatario y la ex
vicepresidenta Roxana valdetti fueron
declarados culpables de los delitos de
asociación ilícita y casos de
defraudación aduanera balletti recibió
una condena similar por un caso de
corrupción conocido como la línea que
llevó a la caída de su gobierno en el
año 2015 la decisión de la justicia fue
dada a conocer en la jornada de hoy en
una audiencia en la que tanto Pérez como
valdetti fueron absueltos del delito de
enriquecimiento ilícito ambos se habían
declarado inocentes de estos
señalamientos que dieron lugar a estos
juicios en su contra
y nos vamos ahora hasta el continente
europeo en Alemania tuvo lugar una
operación policial a nivel nacional
contra integrantes de grupos de
ultraderecha que planeaban un ataque
terrorista contra el bundestag el
parlamento Alemán hasta el momento deja
25 detenidos en diferentes estados
federados entre ellos un ex oficial del
ejército alemán que fue arrestado en
Italia y un príncipe integrante de la
casa real de Joyce
una gran operación antiterrorista en
Alemania las autoridades federales
detuvieron a 25 hombres sospechosos de
organizar un ataque terrorista contra el
bundesk con el fin de derrocar al Estado
alemán lo sospechosos pertenecerían al
movimiento extrema derecha rash bulga
que niega la existencia de la República
Federal instaurada luego de la Segunda
Guerra Mundial y de la derrota del
Tercer Reich de adolf Hitler en su
cuenta de Twitter el ministro de
Justicia marco bushman se refirió a la
operación policial la democracia ha sido
defendida desde esta mañana está en
marcha una gran operación antiterrorista
el fiscal general está investigando una
presunta red terrorista relacionada con
el movimiento ciudadano del raid se
sospecha que se planeó un ataque armado
contra los órganos constitucionales
seis de los detenidos se produjeron en
el Estado Sureño de baviera el ministro
del interior bávaro dijo que los
sospechosos hacen parte de una de las
mayores organizaciones terroristas de
extrema derecha en los últimos años y
detalló los resultados de la operación
hoy se han registrado una gran cantidad
de lugares en baviera total de más de 20
15 presuntos participantes y un total de
seis personas de ese territorio han sido
arrestados como parte de esta operación
nacional y en parte internacional
las redadas contra ultraderechistas se
extendieron a Italia en las céntricas
ciudad de Perú ya la policía italiana
arrestó a un ex oficial del ejército
alemán de 64 años involucrado en el plan
de atacar al understag la operación en
la que participaron más de 3.000 agentes
continúa en cuatro estados alemanes Y
recuerda La desmantelación de recientes
planes de la ultraderecha contra el
gobierno alemán como el intento de
secuestro al ministro de salud
comenzó en la ciudad de Montreal en
Canadá la conferencia de Naciones Unidas
sobre biodiversidad cop 15 con el
desafío de determinar un acuerdo
histórico para salvar especies y
ecosistemas de tener una destrucción
Irreversible los delegados de más de 190
países tienen dos semanas para llegar a
ese acuerdo que puede ser una última
oportunidad para la humanidad desde
Montreal Carolina Villa mediana nos da
más información de esta primera jornada
de la cop 15
este miércoles 7 de diciembre comenzó en
el Palacio del Congreso de Montreal la
cop 15 la Cumbre de las Naciones Unidas
para la diversidad biológica en esta
primera jornada de este importante
encuentro se realizó un trabajo más
logístico se estuvo organizando todo lo
que tiene que ver con lo que va a pasar
en los próximos días y se espera que
para este jueves en la segunda jornada
de la cop 15 ya comiencen a discutirse
aspectos claves de ese primer borrador
que ya existe del acuerdo yo creo que se
espera probar de aquí al 19 de diciembre
fecha en que termina esta importante
cumplir hoy también estuvieron
discutiendo hace aspectos que tienen que
ver con la cop16 que se va a celebrar en
las Turquía y la cop17 que se celebraría
en una ciudad de Europa central y del
este en paralelo también estuvieron
ocurriendo algunos acontecimientos en
las afueras del palacio del Congreso
hubo algunas manifestaciones en horas de
la mañana y a la 1:30 de la tarde ya la
situación estaba en total calma el
operativo policial en los alrededores
del palacio del Congreso se mantiene y
también sigue cerrada la Estación de
metro de Square Victoria que está
cerrada desde que comenzó la cop15 Ah y
lo va a estar hasta que termine
la alcaldesa de Montreal también se
pronunció sobre el tema y dijo que
Montreal recibía a todas las voces que
quisieran expresarse y que al contrario
de criticar estas manifestaciones
consideraba que son algo que esperar y
que de alguna manera las motiva la
celebra
dos semanas por delante para esta cop 15
para alcanzar un acuerdo que tenga un
impacto a gran escala a nivel
internacional con esto llegamos al final
de las noticias Punto Final más
información en France 24 punto com siga
con nosotros
[Música]